james is in nashville to start off at
this hour hi james how are you
pretty good dave how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
so my wife and i actually got married
back here in october actually in
nashville right on the water under the
pedestrian bridge
but that obviously equals joint finances
now so my wife went to
occupational therapy school and she's a
pretty big
student loan from that so her student
loans are around 177
000. obviously with uh the bonding plan
right now there's no
interest accruing they're public loans
until september 30th
as of now at that time so before
september 30th
we would have the ability to pay them
off in lump sum so just pay them off in
cash
so i'm just wondering if that's the best
thing for us to do we would be able to
build up a
emergency fund pretty quickly so we'd be
okay but it's a lot of our non-qualified
assets
going towards the student loans so just
looking for your perspective around this
wow well congratulations on the marriage
um where did all these assets come from
where'd this money come
uh from fortunate pretty blessed i work
in the financial industry
i have a pretty decent income and i've
been investing since i was about 16
years old
um so just over time able to build them
up and we also have a decent amount
and our qualified retirement asset raw
401
and a roth ira as well how old are you
guys
i am 27 my wife just turned 26. wow
and what's your household income
household would probably be for this
year uh let's just call it 300
conservatively 300 grand
you guys are killing it that's what i
smelled good i'm so proud of y'all
well done appreciate that fabulous
fabulous income
okay so let's kind of play these two
things out
one is you wait until september and then
you pay it off
two is you pay it off today correct
correct yep okay and so the difference
is what you would earn on the money
between now and september
correct exactly opportunity cost of
capital exactly
exactly i got the same degree you do and
so um
the uh
i mean we're talking about uh depending
on how it's invested
uh what six months and so
uh six eight thousand bucks
right okay right all right so all of the
data that we have
on building wealth is
based the people that have built wealth
have followed a set of principles steady
and they haven't found shortcuts
and the thing that the way you and i are
trained academically
our mind leads us to um
my wife calls it scheming and scamming
we're always trying to figure out an
angle because we know so much
math it's it's the curse of the math
nerd
we know so much math so we have an
advantage but we know so much math we
can get caught up in the analysis
and almost get paralysis of the analysis
instead of just going forward and
driving the car correctly does that make
any sense to you right
it does make sense it does make sense
and i should have expanded on the
question too because we're looking at
opportunity cost of capital now but
we're in this weird time where there's
no interest accruing i know
on these public loans given covid i know
but the rate is high
so it's eight percent when it does turn
back on so so you would pay it off
it's like it's like it's like a uh
someone that makes
fifty thousand dollars a year has a uh a
ten thousand dollar furniture bill
90 days same as cash do we wait 90 days
and play this
play the float or do we just pay it off
right or or and i'm sorry from the spoke
do we refinance which is probably a big
no
yeah it would be a big problem right
we're not keeping it serious because
again there's no data that says i got
rich because i kept refinancing my
student loan debt
there's just no one has ever done that
in the history of mankind
it runs around in our math brains
because our math brings
but so here's what i here's what i end
up doing if i run the numbers down like
we just did
and all of my gyrations make eight
thousand dollars and you make 300 a year
that's telling me that i'm i'm working
too hard at this situation
and i need to just go with the smart
common sense principle
because the actual math doesn't mount
the squat
if it amounted uh right if if you made
50 000
a year and it amounted to 50 000 then
we'd have to talk about well do we screw
around with this a little bit you know
but this is 8 000 which honestly you
could have made that while we were
talking about it
right right i guess it's a psychological
factor exactly i build up this
non-qualified message exactly and i can
pay off these loans but then a lot of
that you're gonna pay them all it goes
away
yeah every bit of intellect tells you
you got to pay them off by
by the day that first interest is due so
our only real discussion is now to
september
you know that part you've already made
that decision and you're
you can argue yourself down off that
ledge i don't have to do that
so you could do whatever you want to do
i have had
a good benefit of breaking my math nerd
self over into grandma's common sense
and going
i'm getting this crap out of my life
while i can i got this beautiful woman
and when i look at her i don't want to
see student loans
that's exactly right and they make so
much money as he said in his own words
we can build up that emergency fund so
quickly
but dave this is where we get to the
politicalization of psychology you know
where we say oh well they might pay them
off they might forgive them
they might they're not there's no
program where they're giving it well
not not any that have been proposed yet
not yet but for 177
000 for people to make 300 right they've
only been for up to 50 for people who
don't make money that's right but
the politician you're an evil rich
person making 300 you're screwed by the
democrats oh yeah
so it's just it's just better to get it
out of the way and not hope that
something happens you know just
just get it out of the way knock it out
and i get it it's a straight psychology
play
yeah because he's made good money he's
been really smart it's also painful
cutting to check for 177 000 too well
it's like i have a zero percent interest
loan on my car
you know i don't but i'm saying people
call that question why would i pay that
off
because it's not going to be zero
percent when you're done if you keep
screwing around with this you're gonna
end up getting hammered
one way or another with these people and
oh by the way it's not zero percent
because the only reason you get zero
percent in the car lot
is if you pay full sticker price and
only idiots do that
you never pay full sticker price for a
car ever
unless you're trying to get a zero
percent loan so by translation it's not
zero percent because you paid a premium
for the car
back that out of your interest rate
that's just how things work in the real
world y'all
okay so you know it's like
you know i think if i could just
refinance my credit cards and get them
from 18
down to 14 i could really i'd be able to
break through this thing
sure 4 on 10 000 is 400 bucks you can't
buy a biscuit
dude for the amount of math generation
you're screwing around with here
it's just and that's if you back it down
into real nominal dollars folks
when you're looking at these things like
we did with him like james because james
is a very smart guy obviously
and dumb people don't make 300 usually
and so
usually but uh uh but yeah i mean he's
if and if you're not careful you get in
your own way you step on yourself
so i pay it off is what i do today by
close of business i'd be debt free
that's what i would do if i woke up in
your shoes this is the ramsey show